[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم 25 عام مضت على انطلاق رمز افلام
الرومانسيه التايتنك والهي المناسبه تم
افتتاح هذا المعرض التفاعلي الاول والاكبر
من نوعه في العالم اللي يضم على 300 قطعه
يزيد عمرها عن المئه عام القطع ان رح
نشوفها بعد شويه هي بقايا السفينه اللي
قيل انها لا تقال يبقوا معي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اول ما تدخل هذه التجربه تشعر مباشره انك
مسافر تستلم بطاقه ركوب عليها اسم واحد من
ركاب هاي السفينه لتعلم في نهايه هذه
الجوله اذا نجوت
التايتنك الحقيقيين ومثل ما نعرف تقريبا
3000 شخص
معظمهم وذكرت ابرز قصصهم في هذا المعرض
[موسيقى]
والملفد في وسط المعرض نشوف نموذج يحاكي
جبل الجليد اللي ارتبط به السفينه الحراره
من الداخل صفر درجه مئويه ويمكن للزوار من
خلاله استشعار درجه البروده التي رايناها
بمشاهد الفيلم واللي هي فعلا كلش بارده
[موسيقى]
وبالنهايه ومن امام هذه المنصه ياخذ
العشاق صوره بهذه الوضعيه الشهيره وصحيح
انه قصه روز جاك يا خياليه ولكن بالحقيقه
لا تخلو من الرومانسيه ايضا استمتعت جدا
بهذه الرحله شكرا للمتابعه وعوده الى
زملاء في الاستديو لمتابعه باقي فقرات
صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]